when I go to McDonald's I can actually
see the burgers under the heat lamps I
know they're they're sitting right there
you tell me you make burgers I can see
the burgers okay I'm gonna give you
eight bucks hand me one of those Burgers
Elon Musk comes in Pay eight bucks and
we're gonna do these things and I'm like
okay well show me that you actually do
that and I'll consider giving you money
for the time being it looks like this is
probably why he didn't want to buy the
platform it's not just about
whether or not he could monetize it it's
that I'm willing to bet he knew I wonder
that no matter what he does the left
will refuse to work with him he's a
billionaire Communists don't want to pay
for things and they're not going to
they're not gonna pay a billionaire so
maybe he was like okay if I buy this
platform there's a lot of Communists in
this company they're going to quit no
matter what I do advertisers are going
to pull out no matter what I do I better
not buy it that he was forced to buy it
now he's desperately pleading with him
please please I'll do whatever you say